Hey guys, Pete here. Today I'm going to
take one more look at the ending of Dark
and we'll answer a lot of questions i've
seen popping up in the comments of my
videos.
initially i thought about doing a big q&a
but as i looked over the list
i realized that a lot of the questions
are related. to be clear
the ending of Dark is open for
interpretation. there are competing
theories which i'll address,
but i have my thoughts about what the
ending means and those shape my point of
view.
personally i'm okay with differing
opinions. the writers are the only ones
that know for sure about some of these
points, and explaining them would ruin
the effect they set out to create.
so before we dive in this is your
spoiler warning i'm going to talk about
things that happened in the Netflix
series
Dark including its ending. if you haven't
completed all three seasons then this
video won't be for you.
Dark season 3 did an impressive job of
providing answers to all the questions
the series asked.
it's a complicated story though and many
fans were left scratching their heads
about different details.
these can be broken down into categories.
there are some questions that we aren't
supposed to know the answers to like
what happened to Woller's eye.
questions that we weren't shown the
answers to but can make a solid guess
like where did Agnes go when we last saw
her.
questions that are supposed to have some
mystery about them
like what was going on with Jonas and
Martha
seeing the kids on the bridge between
worlds.
some things that we did get answers to
but some fans might have missed like
what was the point of Noah building the
chair
time machine in the bunker. and then
things that really didn't make sense or
i don't have a good explanation for
like why did we see Michael and alt
Martha show up near the cave
covered in black goo. i'll start with a
couple things that we know answers to
and that'll open the door to discuss the
bigger picture i've seen the question
why was noah working on the time machine
in season one
and why was he killing those kids. part
of that was story related
the mystery of it was a good way to hook
fans in
and a way to connect the characters and
their backstories
ulrich for example is a cop in the 2019
timeline and his brother mads going
missing
33 years prior played a part in him
choosing that profession.
it served as an introduction to time
travel and how things were connected
remember as a child helge was the first
person
to travel successfully through the chair
and then as an adult he was
instrumental in helping noah build the
device that his younger self would be
transported in.
so the bunker and abductions helped to
lay out the non-linear story.
as far as why they needed to build a
time machine when others already exist
adam explained this to jonas in season
two.
each machine is an evolution of the one
before
it and even though this evolution
happens in a non-linear fashion
each machine has to be built for the
others to exist.
he used the example of not being able to
build a car
without first inventing the wheel. asking
why noah is building the chair
would be the same as asking why claudia
takes the plans to tannhaus so he can
build the box machine.
it's also worth mentioning since the
methods of using the children seem
harsh that noah is just following the
notes
detailed in the triquetra notebook. the
idea that everything is connected
helps to answer a lot of similar
questions like why does the unknown trio
go around killing people?
they do it because the power plant needs
to be built and the accident needs to
happen
back in 1986 in order for the time
travel fuel to be created.
another example of something similar but
unrelated
is why katharina has the same name in the
origin world.
in adam's world she was named katharina
because when her mother was young
she met hannah who was using that name
and she liked it.
this is neat when you put it together
and you might ask
if this never happened in the origin
world why does she still have that name.
the answer is actually simple adam and
eva's worlds
were created from the origin world. it
came first and she was named katharina
there
everything that happens in the knot was
influenced by the origin world and not
the other way around.
you could apply this to other questions
like why did claudia have a child with
bernd doppler.
well, age difference aside, they are a
happily married couple in the origin
world.
they are regina's parents there so they
would be in the knot
as well. this brings us to the big
picture questions about how things work
in Dark
and the different theories to explain
things. if you watched my how to claudia
know video
then you know that i was leaning heavily
towards adam and eva's worlds
being deterministic systems after
watching the finale.
to me it makes the most sense that these
two worlds were created with fully
formed timelines
where none of the characters can change
anything. a question i heard a lot was
how was claudia able to change things
this one particular time
in relation to the ending. in my view she
wasn't, it always happens.
everything only happens once but in a
way
it's always happening. this leads the
characters
to experiencing things as if they're
happening over and over.
the idea of an infinite loop and claudia
thinking that you know when she talks to
adam
it's the first time in my mind it's the
only time though it's not the first time.
one of the other popular interpretations
is that what she says about things
repeating
is actually happening and that she
passes information off to herself
each time she goes through the cycle. in
that process she figures things out and
eventually arrives at a point where she
has a plan
and she's able to implement it there are
clues that seem to back up both of these
theories
depending on your perspective. in this
version of events we would have to
believe that free will does exist in the
system. that the other characters are
just held back by their desires
and doomed themselves to continuing
their loops this is a fine way to look
at things and i'll admit to liking the
idea that they keep themselves stuck
based on what they want where the idea
loses its appeal for me
is when you start filling in the details
of how that would actually play out i
don't really want to go down that rabbit
hole in this video though
because the details aren't the most
important thing here in my opinion
really the only popular idea that's out
there that rubs me the wrong way
is the idea that the loop and adam and
eva's worlds
still continue after jonas and martha
disappear
to me that's contrary to what the ending
and to an extent the entire show was
about
the creators haven't really revealed too
many details about the ending
but they did say this in a hollywood
reporter interview bo
odar says that he views the ending as
happy
but it can be interpreted as a suicide
mission he talks about the characters
realizing they aren't important and that
they can do
something good by not being there he
says this gives the other world a huge
chance which for him is a very happy
ending
even though it feels very sad. Friese
adds questions
she was concerned with like do we matter
can we change anything
do i actually have free will she talks
about the characters freeing themselves
and letting go making for a satisfying
ending
to me this adds up to what i saw on
screen and what i described in my
claudia video
two characters making a decision to
bring the existence of their worlds to
an
end in my understanding since time
travel will never be created
after the car crash is avoided time is
linear in the origin world
once jonas and martha complete their
mission they essentially
act as observers they observe that
reality and therefore all
other possible states or realities are
off the table
the initial timeline where Tannhaus
created his time machine
no longer exists and therefore adam and
eva's worlds cannot be formed in that
way
they do not and will not exist again one
of the reasons
people hold on to the idea that the
cycle is still
out there repeating is because of the
scene in the bridge between worlds
jonas and martha are separated in the
beginning and they each see the other as
a child through a doorway
jonas mentions it before they disappear
and so well people think this means it's
happened before
since this goes against everything i
just said i'm not a big fan of this idea
but then what's going on in this scene
as i said earlier i think some of these
things are supposed to have some mystery
about them
overall i think this shows their
connection and i think this scene exists
outside of time itself in that way it
just furthers the idea that they will
always have a connection and with that
it isn't
evidence that it was part of the loop
there's an interesting theory that's out
there though
and even though i'm not sure i endorse
it i like the idea behind it
it boils down to this being necessary so
that the seed of deja vu can be planted
between these two
it then becomes the thing that draws
them together and since this is all
happening
outside of time and space there's
potential for it existing beyond the
timelines
and worlds we've already seen it's a
nice idea and who knows
i think it's interesting that they don't
come together and then leave the bridge
until it happens
i also think that since they accessed
the tunnel in the split second
where cause and effect break down it
opens the door
to the connection being bigger than what
we've seen to this point
that ties into the next question i heard
a lot which was
why does it have to be jonas and marta
if claudia discovered the origin world
why didn't she go there herself
i mean i get where people are coming
from with this to an extent
it does seem like a lot of extra moving
parts to bring into the plan
i think part of this is story related
frankly it makes for a better ending
that jonas and martha are the ones to
bring this to an
end they are literally the beginning and
the end of their worlds
to their credit the writers littered
plenty of explanation as to why claudia
thought it had to be them
into the story and if you liked the idea
of the bridge being the point of
creating the seed of deja vu
then this would actually be essential
this one statement
sums it up you two are parts of a whole
only together can you return to the
origin world
some of the other questions i brought up
at the beginning a lot of people have
been asking what happened to Woller's
eye
and i hope part of this is just
furthering the joke
how he injured it isn't important and
the creators were just playing with our
curiosity about it
they decided during season 2 they
wouldn't reveal the answer
and used the interruptions in his trying
to explain to playoff they even went as
far as making the words right
eye a link on his page on the official
website and when you click on it it just
hangs like it's loading the page
indefinitely
where agnes went when we last saw her
travel is another question i heard a lot
since we saw adam give her the newspaper
article about claudia's death
i think we can put it together her
actions in season 2 are the only things
we know about her story so i think it
makes sense that she traveled to that
point in time
another detail that falls into the same
category is the question of who built
the gold sphere time machine
since adam's world has the box time
machine that tannhaus built we can
imagine that he created one in eva's
world too
the show didn't provide the backstory
for this or why it's so much more
advanced
but at the end of the day him making it
is the only thing that makes sense
if we're working from the assumption
that the timelines
were created fully formed to account for
all the other bootstrap paradoxes
it exists as it is because it does
finally the one thing that i don't have
a great explanation for
is the scene outside the caves where
michael and martha appeared covered in
what looked like
cesium i always thought that the michael
scene was included to show jonas's
internal struggles
and were likely a vision or
hallucination the creators may have
added the marta scene
to show how she is similarly struggling
with the new situation she finds herself
in but her being dressed in the same
clothing the original
martha wore the night of the party in
adam's world makes no sense to me
i think it's probably an effort to show
their connection but it's one that
didn't particularly work in my opinion
there are a few other questions out
there that will remain unanswered
like who were the other people in the
sic mundus photo
why were there two different versions of
the conwald family photo
in season one and two why did jonas and
helge get transported to different
places after touching through the
wormhole
but elisabeth and charlotte ended up
together what happened to adam in the
reality where he killed eva
and how did noah travel back in time in
after charlotte was kidnapped and with
those i will bring this video
to an end let me know your thoughts in
the comments
and about any other questions you still
have as far as the mechanics of what i
think happened at the ending
there's a pretty good thread on reddit
that compiled a lot of the explanations
about many of these questions
i'll put a link to that in the
description of this video and you can
draw your own conclusions
when i first saw it i was glad to see
people were reaching
a consensus about some of the things i
was thinking about and i guess
if you favor one of the other
interpretations it might give you
something to think about
it also mentions the idea that jonas and
martha are the souls of marek
sonja inside the knot i haven't really
talked about this because i don't find
it very compelling but i've seen a lot
of you mentioning it in the comments
it's cool if you want to read that into
it but how do you deal with the
inconsistency in how they
manifest compared to everyone else also
the actual marek
sonja and charlotte are part of tannhaus'
story
inside the knot so why would that
connection be necessary
i don't know so let me know what you
think please like this video if you
enjoyed it and please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching i will talk to you
soon